هو ده رئيس المجلس العسكري في النيجر
الجنرال عبد الرحمن تيان القوات المسلحه
في مالي وبوركينا فاسو بالتدخل في بلاده
اذا تعرضت لهجوم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا
في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي المعطيات
التي دفعت قاده الانقلاب لتفويض مالي
وبوركينا فاسو للتدخل عسكريا في بلادهم
دلاله اجتماع مستشاريه الامن القومي
الامريكي والفرنسي والالماني والايطالي
والبريطاني في واشنطن لبحث ازمه ازمه
النيجر ما هي السيناريوهات المتوقعه
الاتجاهات الاوضاع في النيجر
[موسيقى]
ان المجلس العسكري يريد ان يقول انه
مستعدون للمواجهه فانهم وحلفائهم في مالي
وبوركينا فاسو سيكونون مستعدين
ويريدوا ارادوا ان يظهروا هذا الاستعداد
بخطوات واضحه
مجموعه
بالتدخل العسكري لذلك لكي تتم العمليه بين
النيجر وبوركينا فاسو ومالي قررت الحكومه
العسكريه في النيجر بانه تسمح لكل ممالي
وبوركينا بالتدخل في النيجر العسكريا اذا
كان هناك هذا الاعلان من الدول الثلاثه
بين بوركينا فاسو ومالي ونيجر صار لي ماني
وبوركينا فاسو الحق في التدخل في الاراضي
اراضي النيجر هذا يعني اننا بدانا نسمع
اصدقاء الحرب
التي صدرت عن البيت الابيض او هذا الاعلان
قالوا انك كل هذه الدول تدعم الاكواس ولكن
الايكواس تمسك بطرف الخيط من جهه تهدد
بالتدخل العسكري وبالتالي كما لو انهم
يدعمون الشيء ونقيده التحسن عندما تم
استقبال وفد العلماء حيث كان هنالك
استخدام ماليه العلميه والدينيه والثقافيه
بين
النيجر وبين دول الاخرى حققنا تقاربا بين
الموقفين الفرنسي والامريكي منذ ايام
ويبدو ان الولايات المتحده لم تحصل على ما
تتوقعه من مجلس العسكري
وبالتالي يبدو ان هناك تقريبا وحده موقف
بين فرنسا والوقت المتحده اما المانيا
وايطاليا فلم تدعم تدخل عسكريا الولايات
المتحده وجدت ما تريد لانها تريد ان لا
تقترب
من روسيا وقد اعلن ذلك رئيس الوزراء محمد
الامين زين اكد بان النيجر لا تستعد او
ليست مستعده في الوقت الحاضر للتوجه الى
روسيا نكته اخرى وكانت مهمه في نقاشات كما
يبدو لي الا وهي ان
كان يريد الاستمرار في التعاون مع بال
وبوركينا فاسو وحول هذه النقطه بالتحديد
فان توترات بين الولايات المتحده والمجلس
العسكري مستمره
[موسيقى]
بشكل عام هنالك مقاومه لاي تدخل عسكري اذا
ما نظرنا الى الاعلان الاخير من قبل
الاتحاد الافريقي قال
انهم يلاحظون الجهود التي تبذلها لكنهم
اخبروا مفوض الاتحاد الافريقي ان يقوم
بمراقبه
التبعات الاقتصاديه والسياسيه والاجتماعيه
لاي تدخل عسكري هذا الوفد نقل رساله من
مجموعه
وتحديدا من رئيسها بان الاقوى استطالب
الجيش بان يتراجع وحمل رئيس المجلس
العسكري في النيجل اما لا هذا الوفد رساله
بانه لا يمكن الترى يمكن النقاش في كل شيء
الا في مساله عوده الرئيس بازم الى
السلطان
تحدث عنه
من روسيا وكذلك ما تحدثت عنه الصين
والجزائر هذا كله يشير الى قلق كبير من
التدخل العسكري لهذا التدو ان هناك عناصر
هذه الليله تشير الى احتمال ان يكون هناك
تحرك عسكري امل ان لا يحصل طبعا هذا سيكون
كارثيا